Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh.
[LIVE MUSIC PLAYING]
We're really excited
to have one of the best
saxophonists in the world.
He's coming to MIT
because he knows
of the talent of these
students, I mean,
the Festival Jazz
Ensemble is just one
of the best musical
groups in Boston.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There's still close to
a million Puerto Ricans
without electricity.
My grandmother just received
electricity like a week ago.
It's been five months.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
With this concert, the
Jazz Ensembles initiative
was to be able to
collect all this money
and donate it to the
Puerto Rico Recovery
Fund, which is a long-term
vision for the island.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There's still a lot of
chaos, unfortunately,
going on in the island.
So we're just trying to
really create awareness.
Anything you can do to help
is greatly needed and greatly
appreciated by the
folks down there.
I have a lot of friends from
artists to most small business
owners who decided to stay
there and do what they could
to build that country back up.
So I wrote this piece
for them, thinking
about the resiliency
and the courage of a lot
of these people in Puerto Rico.
A lot of the people
are trying to help out
the situation there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
How do we create more
resilient infrastructures,
electrical grids,
housing, water systems--
try to find ways of
decentralizing the whole thing,
so that if like one
tower falls, some people
would be able to sustain their
own micro-grid solar panels
and stuff like that.
So I think that's
where MIT really
comes in, right, is to try to
bring all the innovation that
are in these labs to
come to Puerto Rico--
make a difference
in people's lives.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And we're looking for
the future to have
a bit of like a setup
externship, where you could
have students work
on actual projects
that could benefit the
Puerto Rican community
and society on the island--
brainstorming ideas, and a bit
of consulting and designing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I hope that young
people don't take this
as a kind of a
defeat, but more so
as an opportunity
to grow and be part
of the Puerto Rico of tomorrow.
If the young people give up, the
rest is just going to collapse.
We can't let our country die.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[STOMPING]
(IN UNISON) Hey!
[CHEERING]
[APPLAUSE]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]